Thank you very much May I ask the sisters
side and non Muslim sister My name is
Laxmi I am a journalist I have two
questions The first one is on family
planning I was told by another Muslim
friend of mine that you don't encourage family
planning Now I am sure my
grandmother's generation were more than happy to
produce 10-15 children But given the state
of affairs today I mean how is it possible
to put a stop if you don't have family
planning Now the second question is Muslim
men are allowed to marry four to five times I
think and they don't require their wife's
permission or the first wife's permission to marry I mean correct me if I am allowed to
marry more
number of times So I actually don't see any
logic in this Because I believe it's one
man one woman that's the institution of
marriage So please clarify Thank you sister too
Question very good question but long answer
first question is family planning
that she said the sister in my grandmother's
time produce more children good but now the
world is
changing let's see whether grandmother is right
and you are
right in Islam as far as family planning
is concern family planning is big word but there is
agreement that as far as permanent method is a
concern the Islamic scholars everybody agree that it is
haram then abortion it is prohibited even
abortion is prohibited
unless it is to save the life of the mother in that
case you can do permanent method you can do
abortion for some the doctor tells you that
the lady has a hard problem and if she
conceives again it may be dangerous to a life and
if she has multiple cervix section then for one more
child will be dangerous to health then any
method is permitted so as far as permanent
method  I concern abortion I concern Yamus
agree it is haram because Quran says in
Surrey Anam chapter number 151 verse number 151 that kill
not your children for want of sustenance
Allah Subhana Taala Almighty God Who will give
sustenance to you and your children the
message repeated in Surah number
31 kill not your children for want of sustenance Allah Subhana Taala Almighty God Who will give sustenance
to you and
your children killing not your children is
prohibited form any method but
medical
doctors are called contraception the most common is hypocritical and
we in medical college its a contraception
but we believe it is not a contraception
it is a contraception implantation from sperm has
already met the embryo but it is a
very early abortion it is called as a
contraception the right technical term is
contra
implantation and if you let your imagination a
bit ahead it is nothing but  An early abortion
so this is prohibited there are different opinions and a different method is a
concern because of the prophet's approach the prophet said that he used to do that it is to
interrupt the breaking of the
act and prevent the fluid of the male to
enter the female body the prophet was silent no
one group of scholars said because the prophet was
silent he permitted the other group of
scholars said because they were silent he prohibited there are different opinions
but let's get back
to the main reason so as far as corporate
is concerned that this is prohibited OC
pills oral contraceptives it changes the
physiology of the body Allah says in the
Quran in chapter number 30 verse
number 30 do not change the female body and I by
medical doctor I know there are some people who want to do family planning now coming
to the basic question we should person
wa to do family planning basic question
Let's treat the cause if you know medical doctors
we prefer
treating killing the germs rather than synthetic
treatment one thing synthetic treatment other is
knowing the
cause and killing the cause now broadly major than
two reasons pun family planning non
by bickering and paternity m fam looking after many
children or no by more than more than
doctor f not
in islam solution zakat in islam
one of the pillars of islam is every rich
muslim who is saving
85 grams of gold at the nisab level he and she should give
2.5 of that saving every lunar charity if
every rich human being gives zakat
poverty will be eradicated from this world there will not be
single human being fighting hunger as
poverty is the solution is zakat it is
not killing human beings
second reason baby if i am rich i have money  but i want to
make my son a doctor i want to
make an engineer so i give spacing less
children i can take care of them better sister
i am the fifth child of my
parents if my parents had family
planning i have not been here
today and do you know sister i am a medical
doctor you know because today society the best
profession they say is medical doctor right i am become
and become for society sister fifth child
of my parent if my parent family pl
but i gave up my profession of doctor for
better profession that allah say in quran
in 41
33 it is better speech than one invite people to the
lord to l mighty gd vrs rane and say i am
the one submit my will to mighty gd i chose to become
doctor because i thought it was the
best profession it is a good profession am not
against it but i found better profession from
doctor of body i became doctor of  Soul If I become a
medical doctor or fund 10 people then you come to
your doctor of body you came to your
doctor of soul so one I found a better
profession I change from a doctor of body
to a doctor of a soul so m r boon and ben
for society so it is a facie age for age
spacing is a concern almighty god has given
natural spacing no age luxate anuria
breast feeding the moment you best feed
automatically there is spacing but today's modern
women don't want to breast feed because they will lose their
figure almighty god has given
luxate anuria so now there is a facie what
people think that if you have less children you can educate them better if you raise
and check the
history of the Nobel Prize
winners all of them are not the single child many two second child
third child fourth child
fifth child they all Nobel Prize winners they all are
intelligent so it is a miss understanding
That they recite in the Quran in Sir Anam Chapter 6
151 and Sir Isra Chapter 17 verse 31 it sound similar
the first verse in Chapter 6 151 says
kill not your children for want of sustenance for
Allah almighty God who will give sons to
you and your children this verse is referring to the poor
people if they have one more child in him I will die
and he will die the next verse of Sir Isra
Chapter 17 31 says kill not
your children for want of sustenance for Almighty God will give sons to you
and your children the
order is reverse second verse refers to the rich
people don't worry if he has more
children he will not die he will worry about his children
so God says he will take care
of children as well as
you and now we recite that if you
go to America they will increase population
and the children wear a t-shirt I am my
father tax saver the  The more children you have, the
less tax you pay. Same in Canada, same in
Australia, in India, it's the opposite. Hum Do Hamare Do,
after one, not now, after two,
never.
It's a problem with the Indian
government. You know China has the
maximum population. India is number
two. You know sister today, the two super powers
in future are China and
India. Because of population, so
grandmother is correct. The more population you have, the more
chances you have of the country to improve. China
today is the country which is the
maximum improving
and India is neck to neck fighting with
China. So the difference in opinion is who will be the
super power in the next 20 years. Some are from
India, some are from China. America is nowhere.
Australia is nowhere. Canada is nowhere.
So sister population is a boon. It's not a boon. You should know how
to utilize it. We don't know how to
utilize what we have to tell
the government. We have to use the
manpower to utilize the population. So  Grandmother
was correct that the more children you have she will also be
better and they are third
category
sister if they have less
children i can take care of them better what they say i had to
take the
headache of their children i am rich no
problem money i am not bad my son became doctor
engineer but did have to take care of looking
after the children third category you know there are
certain communities i.e. in
Gujarati they marry and have children
and by the time they are 35
years old 40 years old they child is 15
years 20 years they are sitting on the seat of
the business of father so by the time they are 45 they
can
retire they do to wait till 60 years marry early have children
children take business and
relax their son third category they enjoy life it is better if they have children they take care
of business they enjoy life better so little reason as to
planning is concern
Allah says Imran Chapter rs number  54
Makala De Pla And Opted Allah To Plan
Allah Best Of Plan So If You Feel L
Mighty God Can Plan Your Family Better Live If I Take This Thing Then I
Believe Ilma God I Lay Farm At N Amar Second
Q Ilma Menary Four Times
Five
Times And Don Param Pham First F Was
For A P
Kanan Having More Than One Wife Ilma is the only Reason and Quran is the only Scripture
in the Bible
No Verse in the Bhagavad Gita No Verse in Vedas No
Verse in
Quran If You Read the Hindu Scripture in
Ramayana the Father of Shri Ram Hani Have How Many
Wives More Than One More Than One
Three
Wives According to
Mahabharata How Many Wives He Had Unlimited
No  Unlimited you do not know scripture well know you have
four wives I have no idea not four not
100 not 1000 16000 108
why how wide
168 sow ka muslim fo the problem
shri krishna can
168 wives ka we have four father if you
read the vishnu old chapar number
24 verse number it says a bran can have up
to four if you
read the jesus it gives you permission to have
any wife you can have three wives the bible it gives
you permission to have a wife you can have three
wives solomon haney wid
700 wife it later on the church put a band
christian only one not the bible it is the j
community mad moran one wife it was in
1950 chief by pastor signo that jesus should mary only
one so it is the  It is not the Hindu
Scripture and according to Hindu
Scripture you can marry as many as you wish it
is the Indian
Government in
1954 passed a law called the Hindu
Special Marriage Act which
says Hindu should marry only one it is not the Hindu
Scripture it is not Bhagavad Gita it is
not Ramayana it is not Mahabharata it is not
Vedas it is the Indian Penal
Code the Indian Government which passed the
law in
1954 that Hindu should marry only one but
according to the Statistics of the Status
of the Women in Islam if you read the government
document on page number 6667 it says that
Muslims do polygamous marriages you know the
percentage in India
4.3 How many in India 4.3 Of the Muslim
men do polygamous marriages between 1951 and 1961
Hindu How many
5.67 More Muslims in India  According to
Indian Government in this probe Indian law they do more
polygamous men than
the
Muslim women now let's say
from Quran Quran says in
sara nisa chapter four verse number three Mary is a woman
of a choice in twos three and for but if you can't do
justice Mary is only one this
statement Mary is only one is only given in the
Quran and no other scripture it says Mary is a woman of choice
in twos three and for but if you can do
justice Mary is only one so if you want to marry more than one
woman one of the
criteria of the Quran if you should do justice if you can do
justice you should marry only one no what are the reasons
logical reasons one can have a
permitted son to have more than one wife many non
muslims it is for it is for muslims to have more than one woman more than one
wife it is not compulsory
it is
optional it is not for  Compulsory Being a
Muslim Do you know if I have one wife Do you have
no sister Do you know if
I have any how many two? How many? How many? How many? How many? Have I had
Dharmender or I have Muslim or Muslim or
Non-Muslim or
Non-Muslim? Previous Chief Minister's Name Jai Lalitha Yes Hindu and Muslim Hindu and Muslim Hindu Hindu Famous Personality Famous Personality Yes in India No one wife Yes no local b friend in neighbourhood b colleague in India There are more non-Muslims having one wife Muslim under what
age are they the same age by
nature If you ask any medical doctor he will tell you that
male and female are born in
equal
proportion Girls and boys are born in equal
proportion But any medical doctor any
pediatrician any children doctor will tell you
that the female sex the female child is
older than the male
child in the region there are more there in the male
children are coupled to female children So in
children as it is
the female children are much  Moran male children
's life grows on there are people dying due to
accidents due to alcoholism due to there are more males dying as compared
to
females today if you compare in the world there are more
females in the world as compared to males there are some
third world countries like
India where the male population is moran the female
population and do you know the reason is because
of female fe side and female in fet side
according to an article a program which came
on BBC by the name
later the program is an assignment there was a British
reporter by the name of Emily Bacon she comes
to India and she says that every year in
India more than 1 million feet are being
aboard after they identified that there are
females
she says more than 3000 every day you
multiply more than a million every year
according to the Tamil Nadu Government
Hospital report she gives the
statistics out of 10 female bones  alive do
you know how are you put to death for sister do
you know that Tamil Nadu your state your bill
state according to the government
statistics out of 10 female born alive
in the government hospital for are put
to death there are bill boards put in
Rajasthan and here we say
the spend
00 and save
00000 no what indicate spend 00 the
ultrasonography the sentence of the child a
female about and one
lakh couples are bringing an end how in
fear you stop this evil practice in
India blood country stop the female infant
side stop the female fetus side even in
India the population of female will be more than the
male population if you see the rest of the
world if you see New York alone there are 1
million females more than males in USA
alone there are 7.8 million females more than
males in UK alone there are 4 million
females more than  In Germany alone there are
5 million females more than males in
Russia alone there are 9 million females more than
males and God alone knows how many females are there in the
world suppose I agree
with your philosophy sister you said one man
one woman if I agree with
your philosophy one man one woman and suppose my
sister happens to be in America and your sister
happens to live in America and suppose
the market is saturated one man one woman
saturated yet there will be 7.8 million females who will
not find life
partners one man
one option for 7.8 million females
another man laddi hai wife and become public
property dot Zakir na public property
sash wad sister it is the most sophist wad I can use I can use
most sister worden
public property in America ya no
agon bar he set down with  Wife Define Sexual
Partner Do you not have an
average sum of 10 or
28 sexual partners before breakdown with one
only option remaining? So if my sister
is living in America or my sister is in America and
option is given to me and support the market
rated every man found one for himself and my
sister and if your sister happens to be one
of the women who has not found a life
partner the only option for them is either marry a
man who already has a wife and become public
property any modest woman would opt for the
first sister what would you opt for for your sister
marrying a man who already has a wife and become public
property my sister is too young to be married
so she grows up and if she happens to go to
America and if you happen to be in America
third choice what would you prefer for your
elder sister would you prefer becoming public
property and marry a man who already has a wife
and get  Equal rights in Islam If you have a
second wife you give equal rights In
America the public property has got no
rights She is degraded She is nerd In Islam
she has equal rights She gets respect What do you
prefer for younger sister One She grows
up sometimes it is difficult to speak to the sister
Curt especially in front of such large
audience Anyway I got your answer
sister Thank you and you are silent for that sot
reasons In Islam sister Men have been allowed to marry more
One wife is to protect the woman
not to degrade her Regarding when is it compulsory
the husband should take the permission of
wife It is not compulsory because if she wants to
protect it she wants to protect another
woman A normal woman I agree with you sister
No woman under normal circumstances would like
to share the husband you have to agree This
is human nature but  If the woman is
a good Muslima, she is a good Muslim woman.
What she says is that she lets a small loss take place to prevent
a big loss. She will say I know.
Sharing my husband is a loss for me, but
I would prefer letting a small loss take place
for me to prevent my sister from becoming
public property. She is a good human being, so she would surely give
permission to the husband to another
woman. If she is a good Muslim
woman, but taking permission is not far off, it is
preferred by at least informing the
requirement. So that only justice is done between the
two wives. Hope the answer the question sister, thank
you. The time is running out. We can take probably one or
two more questions only. So brother, on to
my left in the front mic, yes brother, your
name and your profession please. I am above my
profession. I am a post graduate teacher. My
first question is, you call me as a brother then
what is the difference between  The brother and
Muslim brother second one I say that in the
exhibition there is the musical instrument
put into my you are not supposed to use the
musical instrument my brothers are not
supposed to use the musical instrument means some
of the instruments make the mind come
and brings alpha level that is Dadar
Ibrahim Malaysia he said that so it is the
correct reason I want the correct reason to
question the first question is that you call
me brother what is the difference between me and the
Muslim there are two types of brother islam one is
brother in hati one is brother in faith na l the
human being we are the Muslim and non Muslim he is
my brother in hati because we have common
grandparents Adam and correct now a
Muslim is my brother in
faith so if you accept Islam if you
accept if you submit a will to God from
brother of hati I will call you brother in faith so
today if you say fine I want  to
submit my will to God I want to get peace
so from brother I will call you brother in faith
two types of brothers brother t brother in faith come
to second question in the exhibition
you so cross on the musical instrument some
musical instruments being serenity
kamne to the mind according to some
Malaysian y quoted wai it is prohibited there are various
hadi or bald prum who
prohibited musical instruments he
did permit duff one sided open drum during weddings
during et but as for all the other
instruments are concern he prohibited
the reason is because
ten musical instruments they take
you away from almighty God and you see this today
the musical instrument the string
instrument the flute you know you have rock
shows going on and people get frenzy they take
out their clothes and they dance you hear the
film song you know film
song it has music it is meaning one two three what
one  two three one two four six seven eight
and we keep on repeating what you keep
on repeating and then we hear the song the
hero telling the cry main tumhare liye chand tod ke le aaunga main tumhare liye sitare tod ke le aaunga I'll get
the moon
for you I'll get the stars for you we know it's
logical can a lover get the stars for you a
girl can he know but to we resort to music so
you go in and you don't feel what
you are saying and you keep
on repeating it so it takes you away from the
almighty God that is the reason
in Islam bald prophet peace be upon him to prevent
you from get intoxicated it has
some good points also but the loss is more the
Quran says in Sura Baqarah chapter verse
number
219 one they ask you concerning intoxicant
alcohol tell them in it is lost and
profit but the loss  There is more than profit in
alcohol I am a medical doctor I know you know the
beer it keeps you warm so people tell me badar
jakhar you know the beer is good it keeps you warm I say if you want to keep yourself
warm I have honey
honey will keep you warm but the honey dozen
have the kick with the beer gives
you more for the kick and there are good points
but more similarly with music it's more loss
and that's not today we find with the musical
instrument the songs and love we find people are taking away from
the true message almighty god reason blood prophet prophet
magic
instrument
que fruit piculi fruit will lin the float
nut im ma quen im knocking drums and l so
yat ya brothers that also brothers who know that is
Quran brothers who do no Quran that is also
mention the same thing no why don't ya
call like that you are  Talking about brothers
in faith and bad hooti yes I could follow to
answers both the question commented one is on y
talking about flute then flute comes in that only whether it be any one it is
intoxicate so
many of the hindi film songs have got
flutes you know flutes
many of the hindi film songs and even may be
tamil film song malayalam and no they have got
flute it is intoxicate person you know and it
mentions bhagavad gita yano bhagavad gita shri
krishna you
flute to
bring the mind come to go to the
bank river bank and play the flute and do
dancing with gopi woman gopi
correct so don't believe in doing that we
believe we respect the woman when we see a
woman we lose the guess if she is not your sister she is
not your mother she is not your wife when
you see a woman the Quran says  In Sir Noor
Chapter 24 Verse Number 30 that the man should
lower his gaze the woman should lower the gaze we don't
believe in you no gopi woman what ever you said so all these
things takes the person away from the that the region whether it be flute whether it be guitar whether it be
brother
instrument it is prohibited coming to
first answer on the way we say brother follow
the Quran and follow Quran there are many people who say they are
Muslims and yet don't
follow the
Quran to say brother Muslim and not following
Quran so I say brother in faith brother in faith me
brother submitted to god he is not a good
practicing
Muslim so brother hati me you are being a kal
you brother but brother in faith me a person agree he has submitted to god so if you say you want to have peace then
submitting me to god
first has to find out what the will  of God go
to the Vedas it spk now alamti God it tak
now messenger to come his name is prophet
mohammed last
rano if ya bav in the i will tomorrow ya brother in faith
badar in faith i mo chlor to mean badar t b bo que thak ya
sir don't take question n to my
left bak am vikram diter by profession this
quen of my friend the question what is the reason behind
slaughtering the animals in
bak this really safa salas scientific
reason as other rituals have
in islam like fasting a the question is what is the
reason what is the logic behind
slaughtering the animal slaughtering bakrid does it
satisfy Allah does it has scientific reason
like the other Islamic rituals a scientific
reason like fasting at brother Allah says
in sir hajj chapter no 22 the blood and the meat does
not go to Allah subhana taala he does
Not required blood and meat it is your party it
is Taqwa we have from him so we slaughter the animal
not because the blood and meat should go to
Allah it is in most of the other religions in the other religions
you slaughter the goat for the
God and you leave it on the idol may be some body else will come and give it to
the priest of someone
but you leave it to the idol for God Quran says
in Sra Anam Chapter 6 verse number 14 Allah
Subhana
Taala He fed everyone but does not require to be fed
so when we slaughter the animal we don't do it so that
the meat and the blood go to
Allah the logic is it is in the
rence of the incident of Prophet Ibram peace be upon him
not almighty God ask Prophet
Ibram peace be upon him that who do you love the
most in this world after almighty God so he
says my
son almighty God ask him that will you
Sacrifice is the most daring thing you would like
for me
and Prophet Muhammad (peace be upon him) his own
commandment and son to the
Father. Be your own Father. Blindfolded, if you
love me, you should not see me. May your hand
not execute what your God wants.
So in this way the sins continue and are not
about to slaughter him. There is
replacement by sheep
by goat. In remains,
we
command
goat, nor we slaughter the
animal. It is a
reward to the world. The Almighty God does not require human
sacrifice. He was
testing Prophet Ibrahim, not the Almighty God.
Prophet Ibrahim will pass
the test. He did it very well. This prophet
of mine will pass the test. It is reminding
everyone the human sacrifice. Even today,
especially in this country of India,
every day human beings are being sacrificed
in the name of God. It is prohibited where we are being sacrificed.
Reminded The Mighty God Does Not Require
Human Sacrifice Further More No We Slaughter The
Animal We Do Not Believe In The Flesh And The Blood Of Our
Mighty God We Are Animals We Have To Give
Minimum No Third To The Poor People Other One Then Give To
Relatives And Friends
Maximum You Can Keep In One Third Again We Are
Sharing If You Want You Can Give Everything
To The Poor People Also But Minimum No You Have To
Give Not That To Relatives And Friends No You
Can Eat It Is Helping The Poor People Feeding
The Poor People So Here We Are Being Reminded The
No Sacrifice Is Prohibited And We Are Being
Reminded The Almighty God Does Not
Require Blood And The Flesh Of Any Animal At
The Same Time We Are Helping Our Poor People
To Feed Them And Increase The Brotherhood Hope The Answer The
Question  Yes we will take one more
last question from the sister side if there are
non muslim sisters we will take the question otherwise we have
lot of non
muslim brothers here there is one question
from a non muslim she was my neighbour once
and she was always asking this go ahead sister ok assalaam awaikum awaikum alam
my name is husna i am home maker my question to
my neighbour question every muslim follow
quran in the whole world there are two
jamaat the non muslim neighbour loves ask me she says then we do say
one
allah because so many jamaat raising head during
the namaz in y and
shaking first finger a waver n l mum j a
sly and b n navide rope of
allah i g lo
quran muslim ho rope of allah and b n bn
divided as for a making sex can allah
in me chatter number s 9 o prophet if anyone make
sex  In Islam you have nothing to do with him
making sex in Islam is haram all of us have
one label the Muslim that reason in my take
inn chapter number 64 said
Muslim
Balaam
banate people
Ralam
Laam more details you can refer to my take I gave
in the last peace conference during the last
day unity in the Muslim Ummah will throw
light more on this topic how then we can
take one more last question
from non muslim brother first of all I would like
to show my deep human respect for
giving reference to brother in faith rather than brother
in faith it is my simple human sincer
respect for giving preference I like it very much my question is one word is true every body agrees with one good I
think the world is slowly
accepting so multi good are there and
multi religion are there I believe God slowly
likes to prove back on the past  We had one god one earth one religion
now we have come to one earth many gods many religions now god
wants to put us
back to the same point why we have one god one earth one religion how you
think it will be accomplished
by god or by human being then
my second question is between vegetarian
and non vegetarian from
supreme to queen number one god one region one earth now there one earth many gods many
religions how can we get back to one god one earth one reason it is having more such peace
action having more such function having more such
talks concept of god is great religion and what we want only
giving taste do not be such after
giving the taste the people should institute it
my request to you would bet you should institute this there one god there one reason one god is not begun no
images one reason is too  Submit the
mighty God and accept any reason to
submit to God I can accept one God and no one can become one with me I can
accept the peace and the oneness of the mighty God and
reason of submitting your will to the mighty God Coming
to the second question who is better a person vegetarian and a person non vegetarian I would say it did make difference whether a person is
vegetarian or a person non vegetarian I would say it did make difference whether a
person is vegetarian or a
person non vegetarian I would say it is better if being
irrespective of whether it is
not compulsory in Islam a person
should be a non vegetarian In my talk of
debate I told a person can be a good
Muslim by being a vegetarian Having non veg
in Islam is not compulsory but a person should have
non veg Go to debate and with  Jan
the topic of non veg food is permitted by
Quran the pan
ran cut off by single person of male and female either by ne so y
other and the most nerd in the site almighty
God is the person taqwa the only way you can be
superior to other if being taqwa it is by party it is by God knowing other wise being non
veg is lng as you are
following the commandment of the mighty God it
is not a sin I can prove that from
Hindu scripture from the Christian
scripture as well as from the Quran the main thing i hv
is better i h the person taqwa h pa
g consciousness hone kwe
thank you very much you have been a lovely
audience chennai thank you very much and may
Allah taala reward all of us for the hard
work my dear brothers and sisters in
Islam I thank Allah subhan taala for having given us this
wonderful opportunity
Opportunity does not come to most people
and who can know the fact that each and every
person who has visitation has benefited in
some form or the other and also tens of thousands of you who have heard
this lecture live I thank you was
again in Chennai and thank you brothers and
sisters for being a wonderful audience
Jalakam rala
[Music]
bana habil
ya rab ya rab ya rab ya rahb ya
Allah ya
Allah ya rab ya rab ya rahb ya
ah